so first of all no big deal nominated
and performing it's a good American
Music Awards to be you it's a little
Canadian I know I know it feels good I'm
really excited for tonight I'm this is
my probably my favorite visual yeah
tonight listen I'm not trying to say it
but there's a lot of strong females
performing and you guys slid in as like
the male's of the American Music Awards
so what do you have in store for us I'm
performing with Zed so it's gonna be a
little different yeah but it's like not
fully the remix it's a little bit
different it's this middle ground that I
hope people will love Austin Japan is
number one on my playlist of songs to
listen to the in the airport because I
find it very romantic so what inspired
this song is this like that's a good jam
and a good story yeah it's kind of just
a metaphor for getting lost in love with
somebody and then I wanted to just I
just that phrase just kept going on in
my head it's one of those songs that
kind of don't need to make sense to me
tell me about your fashion tonight
because they're always a well dressed to
me I'm saying they're on I have these
red burgundy boots on they're kind of
cool we did this to match what do you
have planned for the fall for holidays
you get some time off shop yeah I'm
gonna go home and see my family
maybe carve some pumpkins and stuff I
don't know I'm gonna try Halloween
costume I don't yeah I need some find
one go said be off easy have you seen
this Zed you go Zed okay because that
will be so funny because in Canada we
say Zed and in America they say Z but
you have a collaboration with Zed it's a
very complicated costume that no one can
understand on this part is there anyone
that you have not met or collaborated
with yet that you're ready to see
tonight like there's Taylor yeah post
Malone I
my trailers next to him and I got to
hang with him and he's just one of my
favorite people ever he's just so down
to earth and be amazing to work with him
one day last thing speaking of hangs he
broke the Internet
hanging with Justin Timberlake what is
that moment like did he call you how
does this all happen he texted me yeah I
mean you have his phone number I do I do
I know lucky guy yeah he just texted me
was like hey man do you want to come
play and I was like I would do love to
do nothing more and I did were you
nervous Timberlake I was okay until the
moment I stepped onstage and that's when
I was like oh my god this is a real
thing
as dreamy in real life kollene as much
as you'd imagine
[Music]